elie annoncé moon
la suite
donc quand on voit les réactions dans le
public qui se dit en passe de
commentaires alors qu'est-ce qu'il ya
une heure de malus en plus chaque fois
dans ce ballet danse m'a lucien jacques
ier le bêtisier qui vont nous marant il
y a et puis il ya toute la phase
d'écriture de préparation enfin tous les
invités qui viennent et c'est ça a été
vachement bien monter c'est le favori
qui avait brisé
c'est drôle ce qui se passe dans le dvd
en ce moment parce que par exemple
surtout pour tenter d'aider la des je
vous ai pas raconté au zénith
il ya un truc où on a le temps on entend
les techniciens qui parlent entre laissé
ouvert les micros les techniciens et on
voit comment les mecs qui balance sur
toi pendant ton spectacle de mayol et
ils me l'ont dit pendant toute la
tournée en soute à gueule tous les soirs
pendant que tu joues à bord parce qu'ils
ont eu des petits casse comme on les
assistants ici ils se parlent entre eux
et mondiaux fait l'enregistrement va te
montrer j'ai trouvé ça vachement drôle
et je les vis dans le dvd dans le bonus
c'est assez créatifs les délais des
lensois moi tout ce qu'on fout sur un
dvd en plus du spectacle parce que les
gens sont de plus en plus exigeants il
faut il faut un beau truc là comme on
appelle ça c'est le machin télévision
non le mois comment réussissez non
comme on appelle ça les cocottes
cotisable sur un petit truc j'étais plus
la vision des vraies commandes supérieur
quand tu mets le dvd tu vois tu as un
menu voilà le menu mois chez nous malgré
cela l'avait dit avant serge petit
replay serge replay
la commande est venu hier n'ont pas fait
du premier rang maintenant c'est le bon
maintenant je le sida mentaux et chacun
pense à gueule alors dans ce dvd de je
vais pas raconter au zénith
il ya des rappels un temps là que les
gens comprennent là on parle pas du
disque en parle pas des petites annonces
on parle du délai différentes
c'est drôle ce qui se passe dans le dvd
en ce moment parce que par exemple sur
ton spectacle sur le dvd de son
spectacle au au zénith je vous ai pas
raconté
ya un moment tu laisses les pistes des
techniciens ouvert non alors ouais ouais
si mal si faudrait sursis gang robin si
nombreux bains je leur en fait c'est
vrai que je suis un peu surpris que vous
me posiez cette question là c'est
marrant la masse avec le dvd en ce
moment j'ai un peu pris au dépourvu
car les 4 quelle prise vous voulez qu'on
prenne au montage ou la deuxième tout
tout tout bangkok y c'est le public qui
décide du montage donc pour mon disent
que c'est vrai que les gens n'étaient
pas d'accord au départ et que je
l'attends non c'est il est plus facile
pour un chameau
ah oui il reste dans le chas d'une
aiguille que pour un riche d'entrer au
royaume des cieux caisse cas sur votre
bonus à vous ni à des scènes coupées
ouais pas mal le prochain spectacle
c'est septembre 2004 au bataclan au
bataclan
vous avez déjà vous allez jouer oui et
c'est même après où j'ai joué dans le
jeu c'est même en 2010 calculé par an
comme un damné
je sais que oui on en 2000 2005 je
connais le jour où j'avais les rues
saint marc l'eau je préfère en 2006 tu
pourrais toi non les mêmes sites s'est
écrasé dans la rue les jours après pour
le planning c'est fou tout le monde dans
la merde quoi là mais ça se réserver une
salle pour le bataclan 112 106 ans tuée
en 2006 toi non pas du tout mais mal
mais tu m'étonnes toi toi ben ahmed
alors un bon 2005 et jusqu'à fin 2005
bon format quand tu dis comme si c'est
le meilleur sosie tes mains on attend
toujours
non mais vous dans quinze ans je les
attends tu sais pas ce que tu vas faire
dans 15 ans si je sais ce qu'on habille
les notes en uc après le spectacle où on
tirait enfin non mais je sais on quand
on joue un spectacle on sait qu'on va
faire une tournée après alors la presse
qui entre les deux jours sert c'est donc
le spectacle est pas écrit mais tu sais
déjà qui va le faire au bataclan
tu fais la suite j cl et fut
pratiquement écrit vrai il y aura quoi
dans le bonus du prochain dvd alors le
bonus du prochain dvd en vigie bataclan
y aura le prochain spectacle d'après